Pyretic enables the notion of both sequential and
parallel composition as we've discussed in previous lessons.
For example, we could match all packets for
a particular destination IP address and send them or
forward them out a particular output port. The
double greater than sign shown here Is the
way of expressing sequential composition in Pyretic. Parallel
composition allows two policies to be applied in parallel.
In this example, we match on a
particular destination IP address and subsequently forward the
traffic out Output Port one. In Parallel,
we apply a different set of policies that
match on a different source IP address.
An output the packets on a different output
port. In Pyretic, the plus operator performs
parallel composition of policies. Pyretic allows an operator,
to construct queries, which allow the program
to see packet streams. For example, the
packets query allows the operator to see
packets, arriving at a particular switch with
a particular source MAC address. The one
parameter here indicates that we only want
to see the first packet that arrives
with a unique source MAC address and switch.
We can then register callbacks for these packet streams. That are
invoked to handle each new packet that arrives for that query.